whether it's microsoft or google i mean
so many people
that have really hit big have gone
against the tide it may seem like you
have no chance it may seem like it's
over
never ever quit if you're a quitter i
hope you quit
right now and stop watching immediately
and people
that can handle pressure
can be entrepreneurs can be successful
he's an american businessman politician
and 45th president of the united states
of america as of 2017
forbes listed him as the 544th
wealthiest person in the world
with a net worth of 3.5 billion dollars
his presidential campaign received
unprecedented media coverage
and international attention he's donald
trump and here's my take on his top 10
rules for success volume
two rule number two is my personal
favorite and i'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best
also guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired by your sharing
and also when you write it down you're
much more likely to lock it in for
yourself
too enjoy
what would be one word of advice you
would have for an upcoming businessman
for a future businessman
um knowledge
knowledge but if it's one word one word
is very hard for that but the word is
knowledge
but you get knowledge through experience
one of the things people talk about is
luck and i do believe that people are
lucky and some people are luckier than
others i do believe that
but there's also an expression the
harder you work the luckier you get
and i can tell you ten instances where i
didn't quit
when it was 1990 the world was coming
down the debt markets were
everybody all of my friends and enemies
were going bankrupt i never did
and but try i mean the times were
actually just terrible
and even today you look at times and you
see what happens and you have to learn
but
the word luck is very interesting but if
i didn't work
really hard i probably would not
almost definitely would not be here
today and unless you had me up as a man
who
at one point was successful but let's
see what a loser looks like
so you have to work hard because it is
true
you can develop luck through hard work
your first book the art of the deal
begins with a simple sentence that many
people might find hard to understand
you say i don't do it for the money can
you explain that
well i do it because i love it if i
didn't love it i wouldn't do it i have
bad days i have good days i have days
somewhere in the middle but
the end result is i love what i'm doing
and i don't do it for the money and i
make money
because probably i'm not doing it for
the money i do it
and i do it well i'm the biggest
developer in new york i love building
buildings i have a lot of fun building
buildings
the fact is i do it for fun i do it for
game i do it for sport
i happen to make a lot of money doing it
if i didn't enjoy it if i didn't really
love what i'm doing
i wouldn't be successful i wouldn't be
sitting with you today what's the
implication of that for someone watching
this who wants to create greater wealth
what's the message in that do you think
well the message is you have to love
what you do if you do it for the money
alone
it's probably not going to work i have
friends where i tell them
get out of this business which is a good
business and go into another business
which isn't as good a business
because they like the other business
better they'll do better
in a less good business so to speak than
they will in the better business because
they like it
going against the tide is great if it
works
now it doesn't always work and you
really have to be smart to go against
the tide because you're going against a
lot of smart people
but when you get it right you'll end up
better
whether it's microsoft or google i mean
so many people
that have really hit big have gone
against the tide
but you have to have great confidence in
yourself you have to be
the right person there are very few
people that can pull it off but when you
pull it off
it's great same thing in real estate you
go against the tide
people are selling you're buying the
tide changes
never ever give up just keep
going forward never stop it may seem
like you have no chance it may seem like
it's
over never ever quit if you're a quitter
i hope you quit right now and stop
watching immediately because you'll
never make it
now you own these incredible casinos and
hotels
and the towers in new york city are
going to build this uh world's tallest
building now in television city
when is enough enough or or will donald
trump never be satisfied with
the deal making and the acquisitions
well i'm like a lot of my friends from
houston i just keep chugging i mean all
you can do is just keep going
life is uh is sort of a pretty short
experience and
you have to maintain some kind of an
equilibrium and and the way i maintain
that is to work
and i enjoy what i do i love what i do
and i hope i do it well
and so i just keep going forward dan and
it's uh so far it's paid off
are you smarter than most people who
would call themselves
entrepreneurs do you work harder what is
the deal with you anyway
well that's an interesting question i
don't know if anyone's ever asked me the
question am i smarter than other people
i think that
without a certain innate intelligence
and without a certain drive you're not
going to be successful
i have a friend who was not successful
at all
but was really up and coming and he had
a thing
he would only fly first class i'm not
saying
do this because for somebody it won't
work but he needed that mentally
right he wanted to fly first class
because mentally
he wanted to think he was the best and
that's it
and even though he didn't have much
money at the time this is years ago
he would always fly i used to criticize
him but it put him in a good state of
mind and he became a very very
successful guy
very very successful and i i've always
remembered that he would never fly coach
he would always fly first last even
though he'd have the means to fight
so look it's complicated
but whatever it takes to train that i've
always believed in positive thinking at
the same time i don't want to mislead
i also believe in aspiring
in terms of what you're doing aspiring
to protect
against the downside you can't just be
this wonderful guy walking around
everything's positive because
unfortunately that's not the way the
world is i love to tell people to think
about the challenges
so that when they do come along you're
ready let's suppose that i have a job
but i have the feeling that i want to
start my own business
how would i know that i'm the right kind
of person for the entrepreneurial life
to me that's the best question you've
asked and it's also the toughest
somebody has a family has a job they
have a nice job they get x dollars a
week they don't have to worry about very
much
it's not going to be great they're not
going to live in palm beach
but you know what they have a job and
it's income coming in
the hardest thing to do in my opinion in
business
is to leave that job and become an
entrepreneur because you're risking
your wealth you're risking your family
your health
your family's health you're really
risking a lot
you have to know in your gut whether or
not you have it to be an entrepreneur
can you handle pressure
can you handle all of the problems that
you're going to be confronted with
and there'll be many many problems but
the toughest job that somebody has
in my opinion in business is to know
when to get out of something and when to
go in something
because that's a very very risky
proposition
you know when people ask me about
success i've just started thinking about
it over the last couple years because
i've seen a lot of it
you have to have an ability to handle
pressure
because you no matter how successful you
are i have many many
friends and enemies a lot of enemies too
i don't care but they're smart
i have a lot of enemies and i've watched
people
and i've seen it and people
that can handle pressure
can be entrepreneurs can be successful
now i have some friends that are
really really smart but they can't
handle pressure
in which case they should work for
somebody do great and have a good life
there's nothing wrong with it because i
almost think that's an instinctive thing
the ability to handle pressure now one
of the things
i tell people about pressure is you know
what they said how do you handle
pressure who's had more pressure than me
hey
yeah have i had pressure over the years
and you know i mean i get criticized in
my hair but it's not so bad and it's
real it's mine
you know it is my real hair
i mean i get killed i had an article
recently that was so good
it was such a great article and then had
one line
but he wears the worst hairpiece i've
ever seen i couldn't show the article to
anybody and it's not even true
but you have to have the ability to
handle pressure
and if you can't handle pressure you
have to know that
about yourself you have to know that
about yourself
so handle pressure
if you can't that's okay but one of the
things i tell people about handling
pressure is
remember because they asked me the
question how do you handle the stress
and you know somebody actually said
donald you're so handsome
do you believe this i love this person
you're so handsome how have you stayed
so handsome
under all this pressure and i actually
thought of it to myself
you have to remember it doesn't matter
god matters
your family matters it doesn't matter
and if you say it
i have some people they say i've got to
be successful
i've got to be they'll never be
successful it's too
crazy they they can't think straight
does that make sense does that make
sense to you that was going crazy
standing up about your success right so
you've got to handle that now he's a
little bit more low-key that's very good
i like that
we've calmed him down so you've got to
be able
you've got to be able to sort of say to
yourself
nothing matters that much other than the
real
big deals with family with your faith
etc people settle for mediocrity for one
reason
they're lazy i've seen it so often
people go into something
they don't want to go that extra step
they know it's not going to be great it
might be good it might be okay it's not
going to be great
they settle for mediocrity they're lazy
i have five children but the three
they're in business and a lot of it's
because of the success of the apprentice
where they go on and people get to know
ivanka
and don and eric but a lot of that was
early upbringing i'd always say to him
no drugs
no alcohol no cigarettes and now i had
forbarron and i i'd
drive him crazy i'd say every time
they'd leave no drugs
no alcohol no cigarettes repeat after me
and i'd have to repeat they go ivanka go
dead will you leave me alone
but i drum it into their heads and you
know you have to get back you have to
get through those
artificial berries i call them
artificial bears because you can do
something about it
until it's too late once it's in your
system it's very hard to stop
like i don't drink and it's very easy
for me not to drink i tell people what
are you drinking for what are you
drinking for
and they don't even understand what i'm
saying how did you
it's amazing when people see you they
can't imagine
no no no alcohol oh would i be in
trouble if i was a drinker
no no no no smoking yeah no smoking
well i had a brother i had a brother
fred who was
sadly an alcoholic a serious alcoholic
and
he was the best-looking guy you've ever
seen he was much older than you he was
much older he was 10 years older than me
11 years older than me and he was
as good-looking a guy as you've ever
seen he had everything going
the best personality i have like a bad
personality compared to fred but
he started drinking and he also smoked a
lot
and but he he started drinking and
i think it started in college frankly
but it got progressively worse
and he was really unable to stop and
he'd always tell me
don't you ever drink so he's much older
than me and it really has an impact you
know when you have that kind of an age
difference
but he'd point don't you ever drink and
don't you ever smoke he'd add the smoke
in it because he smoked and he drank
and it hugely affected his health and
hugely affected
even his look and his you know the whole
bearing
and every time he'd see me and say don't
you ever drink and don't you
so i never drank i mean i really when
you talk about my father i learned a lot
from my father but i learned a lot from
my brother fred
and he set an example it wasn't maybe
the example that people would think but
it really was
in its own way an example we met an
adorable
10 year old girl named megan now megan
was born with brittle bone disease
hi megan my name's donald and you
probably don't know me but
i was watching maury's show the other
day and i must tell you you really hit
me right here
i think you are so beautiful and both
inside and out
i had a little something a little gift
that i gave to maury who's a friend of
mine
and a very good golfer don't ever play
him in golf he's a very very good
believer
and i gave him a little gift for you and
i hope you and your mother have a good
time with it
and you're very special and you just
keep it up and keep up that attitude so
good luck
and you stay in touch
so unbelievable donald trump
donald trump he has his name on more
buildings in new york city than any
other person
and besides that he is one of the most
generous
people i know and he
wants you and your mom to have a very
special check
and when we talk about donald trump when
we he gives out checks we're not talking
chump change here
so look at that do you know how much
that's for
do you get all those zeroes right
unbelievable hi donald
good i really wanted to say thank you
thank you very much bye
i told him that i thanked him and he
said well you're very welcome and he
told me to keep up the good work
thank you guys so much for watching i'd
love to know what did you think of this
video
and in general what do you think of the
volume 2 series leave it down in the
comments below
also i'd love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you
what did he say that resonated with you
the most that you're going to
immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down in the comments below i'm
super curious to find out finally i want
to give a quick shout out to kelly
quinton kelly thank you so much for
picking up 10 copies of my book
and sharing it with your friends i
really really really appreciate the
support and i hope you all
enjoy the read so thank you guys again
for watching i believe in you
i hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love i'll see you soon
you have an enormous skill with branding
and
marketing and rebranding what
what would you give as advice to small
and medium-sized business owners
for branding and marketing well the
first thing is you have to have a good
product
if you don't have the product forget it
but assuming they have a really good
product you have to get the word out you
know i know people
that are better singers more talented
than frank sinatra
you'll never hear about them i know one
in particular
a person who really is talented always
practicing always rehearsing
and yet if the new york times calls for
an interview no no i'm not ready yet i'm
not ready yet they're never ready
you got to get out and do it also you
have to sort of let the press know that
you exist
getting good ratings on things like i
have golf courses that have high ratings
and then once you get the ratings you
got to let people know you have the
ratings
it's a long process and it takes a long
time it's
really just a wonderful thing if you can
have a mentor
having a mentor makes a big difference
in life now
you have to look around who's somebody
that you aspire to be
or to be like but having a mentor is a
wonderful thing
something i do have to ask you is what's
it like to wake up and be donald trump
when you're shaving in the mirror and
you're looking at yourself you're an
icon
what is that like well i'm honored by
your question but i don't really think
about it that way i mean i wake up
and i do shave and i do use a mirror and
all of that stuff but
you know i go to work i'm in my office
early i leave late i work hard i employ
a lot of people lots of education
lots of everything i supply for people
by giving them a check every week
lots of health care frankly and it makes
me feel good i know a lot of people
where
a couple of my employees their wives
have cancer and they're being well taken
care of because they have
a good program under the trump
organization and i'm happy about
that so i just feel i've done a really
good job i've created a lot of quality
and i've given a lot of people
jobs